[Applause]
[Music]
april showers bring may games in any
case a new month is upon us which means
new releases is taking a top-down look
at what May has to offer from alien
space racers to virtual celebrities
there's a lot of variety coming your way
let's take a look at some of May's
hottest games first out of the gate is
Star Wars Episode one racer yes the same
racing game you might have played a long
long time ago on n64 in Dreamcast it's
got new controls for the modern day but
you'll still be pod racing across the
original tracks as Anakin Skywalker
Sebulba and more there's no online
multiplayer sadly but you can still race
others via split-screen and land when it
comes to switch on Tuesday May 12th the
ps4 version was recently delayed until
the 26th so you've got a little more
time to practice your trash talk Hatsune
Miku might not podrace but she will sing
for you in Project Diva megamix this is
the latest entry in the Vocaloids rhythm
games series with over a hundred songs
to enjoy including fan favorites and new
tracks megamix lets you play with
traditional button presses in arcade
mode or use the switches motion controls
in mix mode and it wouldn't be a miko
game if you couldn't dress up with
costumes and custom t-shirts megamix
launches on Friday the 15th there's
another re-release coming this month and
it's the wonderful 101 remastered from
Platinum Games that studio is known for
its stylish action games and in this
case it's all about a team of a hundred
superheroes banding together to save the
world the wonderful ones as they're
called can combine their powers to beat
up the bad guys with giant fists big
blades and more the remaster hasn't
improved framerate graphics and controls
- in case you are wondering the hundred
and first member of the team is you and
you can grab wonderful 101 remastered on
ps4 switch and PC
on Tuesday the 19th you can also ban
together to conquer minecraft dungeons
it might share the Minecraft look but
this dungeon crawler isn't focused on
the resource gathering or crafting of
the original game instead you'll explore
randomly generated dungeons to fight
monsters collect treasure and solve
puzzles you can equip any weapon and
armor you want and you can team up with
friends for 4 player exploration both
locally and online minecraft dungeons
comes to ps4 Xbox one PC and switch on
Tuesday the 26th May has another big
rerelease we need to talk about
Xenoblade Chronicles definitive edition
the cult classic 3ds RPG is making the
jump to switch and it's getting
remastered HD visuals and music tracks
along the way there's even a fancy
collector's edition that puts those
remastered tracks on a minato style
vinyl if you've already beaten the
original game there's still something
extra here for you a new epic to play
through definitive edition arrives on
Friday the 29th and those are some of
the hottest games launching this month
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
everyone and I'll be back with more may
games next Sunday
you